em 2015 foi escolhido um dos três
melhores palestrantes do mundo
segundo a minha mãe né e assim vocês
estão sorrindo aplaudido por que você
não conhece a minha mãe só para você ter
uma idéia eu me lembro de um episódio na
minha adolescência que eu ia sair de
casa e minha mãe disse filho pois
perfume e aquilo me intrigou e eu
respondi sim mamãe e percebi que a
partir daquele dia sempre que eu ia
saindo minha mãe dizia filho pois
perfume e resposta era sempre o mesmo
assim a mãe até que um dia ela perguntou
filho pois perfume e disse mamãe por que
essa insistência de perguntar se toda
vez eu espero fome e ela disse filho
homem feio tem que andar cheiroso
então se uma mãe diz isso por um filho e
anos depois disso ela acredita que ele é
um dos melhores palestrantes do mundo eu
tenho que dar crédito a ela na minha
família sempre foi assim a gente sempre
fui muito sincero e parte do que eu
venho dividir com vocês têm a ver
exatamente com o papel da família no
desenvolvimento da gente né eu sou
professor como disseram
o professor paixão embora algumas
pessoas vê como assim paz ensino físicas
as coisas parece que não
não não se juntam e eu sempre digo que a
paixão por algo passa pela prevenção
deste álbum
eu acredito firmemente que se você
conhece os porquês das coisas
qualquer que seja essa coisa se torna
apaixonante se torna maravilhosa se
torna incrível então descubra os
portugueses é por isso que a gente está
aqui hoje para falar de alguns deles e
aí eu me lembro de novo remontando à
minha família que eu tive eu posso dizer
que sorte nesse aspecto de ter nascido
no seio familiar de pessoas que
estimulavam as outras e quando eu me
tornei professor eu vi o quão diferente
isso é na realidade da maioria dos
estudantes que tenham tido o prazer de
conviver ao longo de 25 anos de sala de
aula e eu venho aqui fazer uma
provocação para vocês
pensar sobre como a atitude
em relação às coisas corrobora para o
sucesso ou não na realização dessas
coisas eu vejo muitos estudantes que
passam pelas minhas salas de aula que
tem a mesma formação enfrentam as mesmas
provas e tem resultados completamente
distintos ea gente pode discutir várias
razões para isso
em um delas eu queria dividir com vocês
que acredito ser uma das mais relevantes
que é a atitude mental que a gente tem
diante das coisas
é fato que ao longo da nossa infância
a gente escuta muito mais vezes não do
que sim até porque criança está em fase
de descoberta e de vez em quando
descobrir as coisas impõe riscos é quem
aqui não lembra se tem criança em casa
da fase que a gente descobre como fazer
uma campanha de mãe
alguém sabe o que é uma campanha de mãe
é sempre que você faz alguma coisa só
para ver sua mãe gritando não né
imagine um bebê descobrindo os seus
arredores engatinhando de repente olha
pra parede e ver aquela coisa que parece
um rosto grudado na parede com aqueles
dois furinhos das vezes um terceiro
encarando ele vai chegando perto é uma
grita e não ele olha pra mãe desconfiada
da mais um passinho a mãe grita não e
ele percebe que cada vez que ele se
aproxima daquilo ali a mãe grita não e
para validar essa idéia é que ele faz na
primeira oportunidade
olha pra amanhã antes engatinha em
direção à tomada e alguém grita não e
ele sorri
não porque ele é um monstrinho mas por
que ele está fazendo ciência ele está
validando a idéia ele fez uma hipótese
fez um experimento e descobriu que
funciona toda vez que ele aponta o dedo
à mãe grita não até que um pai maluco
como meu eu disse à minha mãe seguinte
quando ele estiver indo você grita não
firme mas só uma vez e eu vou correr
para o quadro de luz e aí minha mãe que
tinha mais medo do meu pai do que
acontecer comigo aceitou a proposta e me
viu engatinhando e olhou para mim com
aquele olhar marejado e disse não e eu
fui só que minha mãe não disse
quando não e aí eu perguntei o é tá
pensando que eu não vou eu vou e nada de
não aí eu coloquei o dedinho minha mãe
olhando pra mim triste eu colocando de
dinheiro olhava pra mim triste eu
coloquei o dede meu pai escutou a e aí
ele desligou e aí a partir daí eu
entendi comum não pode ser importante na
vida e toda vez que alguma coisa ia
fazer minha mãe dizia não fazia assim
porque eu achava que aconteceu a mesma
coisa então veja como a família tem um
papel determinante ainda hoje às vezes
quando estou nervoso cruz o simon
mas eu não vim falar de história triste
não tá embora a maioria de nós se voltar
para a infância vai lembrar de algum
episódio onde um não talvez tenha
servido para você para criar uma crença
limitante
se vocês fizeram um pequeno esforço
mental é bastante provável que você
lembre de algum momento em que você
queria um apoio e de repente a sua
família disse não não isso não é pra
você
não não não faz isso e é na não é assim
não
em meus alunos de vida em comigo isso eu
também recebi alguns nãos
alguns foram bem chocantes é como a
gente acabou de ver mas eu acho que a
gente pode fazer uma ressignificação
disso eu gosto muito de dizer que sou
pernambucano porque assim como o pessoal
aqui do sul
nós temos muito orgulho de ser quem
somos né
é muito comum que nossa formas que antes
da gente de termos o maior carnaval
na verdade o maior bloco carnavalesco do
mundo o maior são joão chega vamos até
dizer que temos dois rios que se juntam
para fazer o oceano né
e aí todo o nosso é o maior ou melhor
inclusive de lá nasceu o maior canal de
ensino de física da internet brasileira
do qual eu faço o papel de representar
aqui agora e muito dessa autoridade que
nós investimos em nós mesmos
tem a ver com a postura que a gente tem
desde casa e eu acho que essa postura
mental muda muito os réus
anos e para falar sobre a importância
disso eu queria lembrar um episódio que
eu chamo intimamente de a fórmula do
chocolate infinito professor de física
colocar a turma já faz um carinho de an
mas calma não tem nada muito confuso não
são só quatro letras l que vp forma eu
tinha cerca de 9 anos 9 para 10 anos
provavelmente e ganha uma caixa de
chocolates como toda criança fiquei
muito feliz com isso
fui para a escola com essa caixa de
chocolates em parte para me exibir com
ela em parte para fazer novos amigos
comer chocolate
fiz a bobagem de abrir esse chocolate no
final da aula antes do intervalo e
lógico você abre uma caixa de chocolates
onde tem um bocado de criança junto que
acontece com ela parece um buraco negro
é tudo conversa pra ele e aí eu
assustado não não parei meu momento no
time da minha mãe da minha família e eu
disse só troco por moedinha e aí o
pessoal aceitou a proposta daqui a pouco
uma dieta chocolate uma de chocolate
godiva chocolate peguei um pra mim que
não acabava ea olhar pra caixa vazia ela
não estava vazia
ela estava cheia de uma dias e quando
contabilizei as moedinhas eu percebi uma
coisa incrível
juntando moedinhas eu conseguiria
comprar duas caixas de chocolate e aí eu
pensei vendo um tem duas separam pra
comer vendo um tenho duas e para uma pra
comer vendo um empenho do chocolate
infinito
aquilo foi meu primeiro encontro com
nirvana e aí eu cheguei casa
entusiasmada que ele pintou o gordinho
rosado gritando para o pai que é
empreendedor querendo fazer orgulho do
pai
ai pai nunca mais o senhor vai precisar
me dar dinheiro pra mesada intrigado com
o senhor outro eu descobrir a fórmula do
chocolate infinito e aí esperando aquela
comemoração em casa meu pai me abraçando
todo mundo em festa minha mãe ao redor
todo mundo dançando o que acontece
meu pai me olha com a meio inquisidor
explica pra mim essa história de
chocolate infinito já foi um choque
até então a visão que eu tinha na minha
família é que a família empurrava para
frente o tempo todo e quando eu tinha
tido o meu grande encontro
roberta meu pai de uns calma lá e aí o
bom pai é o seguinte o pegando um
chocolate de se leva para escola vendo
aqui 12 olha só que legal só param pra
mim vem do outro tem 12 e param pra mim
e vendo o outro tem 12
e aí quando eu disse agora ele entendeu
vai bater palmas a ele disse o é
e no final de semana como é que vai
fazer essa multiplicação não tem aula
sábado e domingo
aí eu parei assim impactado pela
pergunta que eu esperava festa mas é só
responde para o seguinte eu não seja o
meu caixa de chocolate todo dia então
aquela caixa que eu vou acumulando
guarda no final de semana de tempo para
segunda-feira a ele ok e nas férias que
são 30 disso meu pai realmente querem
derrubar né
a spy eu só tenho férias uma vez por
semestre não é possível que ao longo de
um semestre não consiga fazer uma
pequena reserva que garanta caixa de
chocolate para o retorno a ele ok isso o
pessoal abusar dos seus chocolates e foi
uma sequência de perguntas um atrás da
outra a cada resposta que eu dava lhe
dava uma lâmpada de volta e meu pai é
muito mais experiente um repertório
muito maior do que quando eu tinha 9
anos e aconteceu voltei frustrado pelo
meu quarto
quase aos berros de choro não fiz isso
porque lá no nordeste cabra da peste não
tem esse negócio vantajoso não volta p
mas não volto chorando
tive uma noite terrível e por isso me
lembro dela até hoje esse episódio já
aconteceu faz mais de 30 anos e eu me
lembro exatamente a sensação dolorosa da
frustração daquela conversa com o meu
pai
outro dia fui pra escola meio descrente
do chocolate infinito mas fiz a minha
tentativa e quando volta de meio dia tá
lá meu pai eu esperando de novo aquela
cara inquisidor ampb algum que é que
vocês acham que fez ele chegou com 20
caixas de chocolate e destaque meu filho
pra você começar seu negócio
e aí quando meus olhos brilharam e olhei
nossa ele entendeu a fórmula do
chocolate infinito
ele me puxou pelo ombro olhou
profundamente mesmo com todo o amor que
um pai pode ter e me revelou a
verdadeira fórmula do chocolate
frito ele disse mais ou menos assim
filho
toda vez que você tiver algo de seu
verdadeiramente seu que você acredite
profundamente que aquilo que te fará
feliz sexy das pessoas que possam
potencializar as suas habilidades e
tenha firmeza de caráter que hoje a
turma chama de resiliência e tem a
firmeza de caráter na busca do que você
quer alcançar pois quaisquer que sejam
os desafios você poderá transpôs isso
ficou tão fortemente gravado na minha
mente que eu transformei isso não a
hashtag para dividir com o público me
assistir pela internet um público que
normalmente é desfavorecido porque
nasceu num ambiente de poucas
expectativas porque teve uma formação
deficitária por várias razões e que
escutou praticamente a vida toda não é
pra você não dá pra você não é seu
destino não é por aí
não não não e é sempre que estou
promovendo algum encontro falando pra
qualquer que seja o público eu quero
lembrar aquilo que meu pai me ensinou
como a forma pra você ter sucesso e
conquistar seus desejos não dizendo que
é fácil por isso mas dizendo que é
possível
toda vez eu lembro do meu pai disse que
eu traduzo nessa forma lq vp e eu divido
com vocês que provavelmente têm sonhos
metas algumas frustrações alguns desejos
algumas coisas que se quer você colocou
pra frente o desafio de repente você a
mudar de postura mental em relação a
esses desafios e escrever um lugar fácil
de você encontrar quando você sair daqui
l que vp2 como ensinou meu pai aos 9
anos e obrigado meu pai por isso
qualquer que seja o desafio que você
tenha pela frente se você se cerca das
pessoas corretas que podem potencializar
suas habilidades e tem força de caráter
para em busca dos seus sonhos todos são
sonhos conquistáveis
l o que vê p
lembre que você pode
muito obrigado